5 54 on your wednesday morning so this
right next door we should not treat it
like it's another world away especially
when it affects your drive to utah
remember once you get past mesquite on
the i-15 you've got 29 miles worth of
the grand canyon state that you got to
get through yeah and there is a friendly
heads up from arizona department of
transportation here's what they're
talking about they just started a
three-year-long project to replace this
mile-long bridge over the virgin river
near the town of littlefield the biggest
impact only one lane of traffic being
allowed in both directions 24 7. so
depending on the timing of your trip you
could be in for long delays not only is
there a web page with great information
they also have an app that frequent
drivers through the area might want to
consider downloading it's called virgin
river bridge we've got those links as
well as all of our driving you crazy
stories on our website eightnewsnow.com
click traffic then driving me crazy
buckle up drive carefully please put
down that phone if there is something
driving you crazy the email address
traffic eight at eightnewsnow.com